Wow welcome to this video playing
subplots key I am subplots key say I
guess a blot scheme yeah that's really
his name okay um let's close that I was
irritating so d 46mm came clings indian
or modern got a modern details yeah
check then play some quick musa for a
change shoot d7 it's a bit unusual
setting it up like that I mean not bad
just kind of uncommon okay i'm always
going with this g4 idea here maybe I
could have no it's okay kind of late 94
may be preventing night c5 but I can
maybe play before here it's a bit early
but the let's try maybe that's a bit too
early age 6 Wow didn't see that one
coming so I'm going to secure this a
little bit more so hom 95 Wow
interesting move but is it any good okay
I cannot really ticket taking it looks
looks wrong so going to go back each for
I possibly g5 as an idea but I think
should see that I'm completing
development ok so H for
okay so now I was thinking probably to
take and go f4 yeah let's do that go a
form for possible g5
yeah at least I was quick about it
Jablonski another plate in before right
now yeah I'm the SSC you really have
some some regulars you know that you
meet all the time yeah Yardbird and so
on but you also sometimes get to play
title and players with really high
ratings that that you never never met
before or heard about before isn't he
just ignoring this ok I'm going g5
so with this might have six that was the
idea here then I'm undermining him there
and get me should be five and so we just
does not care about it well okay so
check check angling for be five I worked
you three maybe hmm okay I didn't think
about it
huh not sure does it matter much and put
it here hmm that's what was necessary
we'll be fine i can let start be 5m k
just tell us this seven solo q 144 ruka
d8 but he kept us this with the with the
Rope t3k
did I respawn this position that was so
good disposition whatever what a shame
really any idea here 95 or something no
I'm night here actually the ship cannot
escape maybe you can move the king now I
cannot hear
doesn't you have to take their or not
hmm really it's an alternative I don't
see it wow so batik here I'm worried
19th Tintin wants to pushes each panel
and the escorting a poner maybe
hmm
and then this point ok I'm going to
check the connected pesos IAM mf5 hm so
I have to go back FIV can now take
now rabbit dead end game is no good what
a strange game what a strange game yeah
why reasons he defended that very well I
mean this position was was must must
have been good for white there's really
no question about it here isn't this
good for white I cannot believe it and
why I didn't see Ruth these three of
course the engine wants to go see 5 and
so ok f5 here was winning ok and that
that I couldn't believe here this is
kind of kind of setup so this wins ok I
was too mean g5 just look good but this
is much much stronger yeah ok this this
is a disaster something like this yeah
that's a very clear winner chua lee ok
so this is why I spoil the chance I
thought that this should be good as well
but under really wasn't Jack I mean not
bad but not not great yeah I didn't I
overlooked that move of course but still
it feels weird that I should be mercy or
something with all that activity ok will
be one wins but ok this is the this is
the this area where with human play it's
very difficult I mean this move wins but
why exactly and probably what I can mmm
what is the threat even moving this
bishop and then this night is overloaded
so that i can take here hmm maybe the
engine wants to play Luke age three here
yeah yeah well normal moves don't don't
cut it yeah this is this is really a
disaster for black now ok this is this
is basically impossible to find and here
King c8 is the only move that very well
played King see aid that's the only move
I mean stuff like that ok that's also
good i'm probably
yeah it's coming around if I do
something like this for example here
check yeah this is coming around him and
there's also the a5 threat now then this
is really bad it's really bad he didn't
even have to find King c8 means that
this is this is better what the engine
is giving check so it's probably still
some kind of draw and very well defended
jinx okay this seems to be a mistake
should be forward Sam okay that this is
useless I mean you can what the engine
is giving is all nice and good but in
with 40 seconds you just have to play
based on gut feeling and while the
computer has certainly am able to
completely or correctly evaluate this
pollution despite your calc and the
question is how much time does it need
to assess it properly at depth 30 stock
versus giving 000 but you never know
exactly it could be one temple and now
i'm here i'm rudy really lost OG six
drawers wow didn't even think of the
move ok i didn't have much time but
anyway geez 6 i'm king here c5
and Bishop a to white even wins and
again be sure way to white wins so he
has to go fishing me six f5 that's a
funky line ticks ticks e to g ade and
draw Wow tough game but he defended this
very very well when it was under
pressure okay f5 here f5 here that was
that was really pretty clear win at five
and then g5 i played this how much time
did i spend that it's kind of
interesting now played that rather
quickly I just thought that it should be
good but if I was really a much much
stronger option okay well thanks for
watching